RICK HARRISON: What
can I help you with?
Well, I've got a
really cool half dollar.
RICK HARRISON: OK.
It is a 1906, $0.50, improperly
cleaned, John W Gill.
And what is that supposed to be?
He was one of the
victims of the Titanic.
RICK HARRISON: Whoa.
FREDERICK: This coin is an
incredible link to history.
One of the most famous
maritime disasters.
It has an unbroken
chain of pedigree
all the way back to 1912.
I paid $75,000 for the
coin about a year ago,
but I'd really like
to reappropriate
funds and buy some more toys
for some of my collections.
RICK HARRISON: God,
this is pretty amazing.
You know, everyone knows
the story of the Titanic.
You know, it was
the unsinkable ship.
FREDERICK: Absolutely.
And the big problem was, it
was a new steel process, which
made the steel
really brittle, so
when they ran into an iceberg
everything started breaking up.
And it sank in a few
hours, but there was a lot
of floating bodies afterwards.
There was a few
ships that came by.
Anything that was on
their body was cataloged.
It was sealed up, sent
back to the family members,
and they were buried at sea.
Yeah, these guys
picked up 239 bodies.
He was tagged body 155.
RICK HARRISON: Hm, OK.
So how did you get it?
I bought it from an avid
collector about a year ago.
OK.
And so this was auctioned
off at one point?
Obviously, you got
the catalog here.
It's like, 2002.
FREDERICK: 2002, yeah.
It was auctioned on
the 90th anniversary
of the sinking of the Titanic.
RICK HARRISON: OK.
This coin by itself would
be worth $40 or $50,
but the fact that it belonged to
someone who died on the Titanic
is a complete game changer.
And how you looking
to get out of it?
About $125,000.
And where did you come
up with that figure?
OK.
A $1 bill that came off of one
of the survivors of the Titanic
sold for $125,000.
Now, the story of the
Titanic isn't the survivors.
It's the victims.
So kind of figure this has to
be worth the same kind of money.
It's got a million
dollar story behind it.
I'm a little bit intrigued.
Let me call a coin
buddy of mine.
Let me have him
take a look at it.
Absolutely.
See what he thinks about
it, and we'll go from there.
OK?
- Fair enough.
All right.
I'll be right back.
Take your time.
This coin is one of a kind.
It's a wonderful
link to history.
And I really would not
go less than $50,000.
This is what I
called you about.
It's a half dollar
supposedly off the Titanic.
Wow.
It's a fantastic item.
RICK HARRISON: Do you
know anything about it?
Well, John Gill was one
of the unfortunate victims.
He was 24 years old,
second class passenger,
left his new bride
to start a new life.
And there are very
detailed records
that I was able to
access that described
the kinds of things that were
found on Mr. Gill's corpse.
There's a gold watch.
There's a gold ring
with his initials on it.
But there were coins in there,
and this is one of them.
RICK HARRISON: Cool.
This wouldn't be the
first item I have actually
handled from the Titanic.
Something like this
is highly unusual,
and collectors really line
up for that kind of thing.
RICK HARRISON: So, what
do you think it's worth?
Well, apparently this coin had
sold in 2011 for about $3,850,
and then again in 2014
for about $21,000.
A coin like this
really has to reach
the ultimate audience
where you could justify
charging much more than that.
So $21,000?
Right in that ballpark.
I would have to think
that even at $21k,
it was in the wrong auction.
That's it would seem
to me, they missed
the wrong target audience.
DAVID VAGI: So, with an
item like this value,
it was only determined when
several extremely interested
parties are all aware
that it's selling,
and they have the
opportunity to compete.
There is no such thing
as an accurate value.
RICK HARRISON: OK.
Thanks, man.
I sort of got the gist of it.
- All right.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
FREDERICK: I understand
where the expert has come up
with his number
from, but I think
it's value stands
on its own, not
what it sold for previously.
I mean, if it sold, like
a year ago for $21,000,
there's no way of
justifying $125,000.
I just don't see it happening.
It's something I'd pay
like $10,000 for it,
because it's something where
the price waxes and wanes.
Just depends on how cool
the Titanic is at that time.
So I mean, is there a
realistic price you'd
be willing to take for it?
I guess I'd really
need to be at $75,000.
Yeah, I mean--
There's no way we're
going to make a deal then.
- Understood.
- OK.
Have a nice day, man.
You as well.
Thanks so much.
I think the offer of $10,000 was
a bit shocking, quite frankly.
This seems to be
so far below what
other people would value it at.
It's hard for me to
take it seriously.